vous êtes là l'invité aujourd'hui trop
cute cher je voulais dit elle s'appelle
mylène farmer
bravo mathieu c'est par kurt handicap
c'est un vrai nom ici m'ont vraiment
c'est pas un pseudonyme
bon je te le dis ça sonne bien tu n'es
où je suis né à montréal au canada
tu les québécoises je suis québécoise
donc et puis je vis en france depuis
maintenant huit ans et je suis plus
française que canadienne n'a pas
l'accent du tournant du tout j'aime pas
l'accent canadien
pourquoi c'est j'allais dire c'est un
accent vulgaire jeu fuira c'est un peu
fort mais c'est un accent que j'aime pas
qu'il n'est pas très fan du nantais
quelqu'un qui me donne l'impression de
parler mais grand chose tu devrais
commencer pas du tout je t'aime j'ai
l'impression que quelqu'un d'un peu
positif
je suis quelqu un wiki un caractère et
même un sale caractère mais pourquoi il
dit ça toi parce que parce que ça doit
être vrai les techniciens vous le diront
d'ailleurs ils sont derrière la caméra
ne peuvent pas maintenir ou non mais
dans le métier avant c'était quelqu'un
d'un peu dur dur mongenan quelqu'un qui
aime les choses bien faites donc
j'essaye moi de faire les choses bien et
j'aimerais que les gens pensent que les
méchants ouais mais t'as pas
l'impression que qu'on peut on est
obligé travailler avec tout le monde par
exemple quand tu fais ma mort at her ce
grand tube qu'on va découvrir dans
quelques instants
ce n'est pas toi qui écris ni composent
n'ont fait nous formons
une équipe de trois personnes il y as
girondin laurent boutonnat et moi même
les deux garçons compose écrit une
musique et paroles et puis moi
j'interprète donc tu m'as pas répondu
c'est pas simple de travailler en équipe
faut tout le monde c'est difficile mais
c'est quand même très agréable quand on
est très lié c'est important d'avoir des
équipes soudées
tu es très lié avec avec les gens et on
calcule les calculs travail très liés ou
et je les vois je vois ces deux
personnes tous les jours depuis un an et
on s'entend très bien
tu voulais faire de la chanson tu étais
tu as fais d'autres choses
je m'étais plutôt orienté vers le métier
de
monitrice d'équitation et ensuite j'ai
bifurqué vers les cours de théâtre
et puis j'ai terminé par une petite
chanteuse s'est très bien d'accord tu
t'entends des biens avec les chevaux
très très bien d'accord on sait jamais
en fait on va écouter chanter même
farmer tu veux quand je veux mettre mes
lunettes puisque ça s'appelle maman 20h
puis vous aller la retrouver en quelques
instants mylène farmer puisqu'elle est
l'invité de rock in chair et attention
pour les questions ça va barder suite
après a tout de suite